it's hard to appreciate how dreadful
West Mosel is families are being torn
apart here and there is nothing that can
be done to stop it
they're being murdered for just trying
to live there just outside the old city
the disused shop is an emergency room
civilians targeted by Islamic state as
they try to escape
foreign medics doctors and volunteers
struggle to deal with the influx of the
engine
they're ferried here on Humvees and
trucks bundled inside the most seriously
hurt
are put into ambulances to take them to
the proper hospitals here though there
is no time for anyone but the living
room those who didn't survive
[Music]
all around the work to save people goes
on these survivors are terribly
traumatized the news that loved ones
died in their terrifying attempt to
escape is overwhelming he's surrounded
by bodies everyone trying to leave
Islamic state areas of target men women
and children families sit together
outside resting before they continue to
reception centers the most remarkable
thing is the resilience of the children
their first food safe now after weeks of
hiding from the fighting when they will
return home
nobody knows some boys carry their
possessions in a rug
sharing the weight between them but
that's all they've got groups of people
were trying to get out of the old city
it's just on the end of this street
we're told that Islamic state fighters
perhaps dressed in uniforms actually
gestured for people to come towards them
and then blew themselves up this is the
first point of safety
that's where medics came and started
treating them before they were being
taken away there's going to be a lot
more of this civilians deliberately
targeted Iraqi soldiers head back
towards the battle space looking for
more injured smoke from the latest
suicide bomb rises in the air how many
people are left inside isn't known it's
likely tens of thousands
even now contemplating their escape
knowing of some of them will simply not
make this is just one day the casualties
barely stopped coming we witnessed a
single day miss like this every day
still Ramsey Sky News West mobile